thank you thank you for the invitation
it's been a really a wonderful semester
here in fact most of the work on me I
talked about today is is worth it
actually was done here with some of the
game participant um so we've heard
already about in several talks about
this issue of getting conflicting signal
from different genes when you're doing a
phylogenetic analysis I suppose you
you're trying to reconstruct the species
history of a bunch of organisms um
different genes might support different
trees and we've seen many reasons for
that today one is this incomplete
lineage sorting problem which is
population genetic effect which I will
remind you where it is in a second
another issue is standing pointed out is
is this issue of gene tree estimation
error it's a you're reconstructing a
trees from finite Lang jeans and you're
going to make some mistakes and it's
sort of a fundamental questions to try
to understand what sort of the inter
interaction between these these two
things I think I can be really should
have said this up great for me yeah I'm
going to give you the sort of
theoretical perspective the perspective
that's been very little or no really
work on on this question of incompletely
image sorting and G tree estimation
error and I'll tell you some sort of
preliminary results about a bond back
here okay so let me just I'll explain
the quantity versus quality bit in a
second let me just start by setting
things up and reminding you what would
this ink illegal intercept sorting thing
is in and I'll explain the kinds of
questions that I'd like to be able to
answer ok so we've seen this picture
many times today let me just go through
it one last time make sure everybody
knows what I'm talking about so what is
this incomplete lineage sorting problem
this is caused by the failure of two
lineages to coalesce in a population so
suppose that you're getting one gene
from an individual in this species
beginning a gene and a copy of the gene
from an individual in that species if
you trace back there leaning edges right
so from ancestor transistor the sort of
implicit assumption in standard
phylogenet
macau's this is that as soon as you get
to this joint population here these two
lineages immediately call us and what
happens afterwards the mutations up
there are sort of shared by the the two
lineages there but in reality you know
if you have a large population there now
it might take a while for these two
lineages to actually meet right I'm
following their ancestors until they
actually choose the same apparent and so
in particular if you're estimating the
coalescence time between these two
individuals while this closeness time is
going to overestimate the actual
divergence time which is this branching
of the population itself now things get
even more interesting up here if you
have a case where maybe the population
is so large that these two lineages
actually never even met in that
population and instead enter the next
population and we're joined by a
lineages coming from another a lineage
and what happens in that case is that in
this case right see might end up
coalescing first with a more more
distantly related species which is in
this case d right so and the reason this
is interesting because now if you look
at the not only just the claw sometimes
but the actual gene tree topology you'll
see that C is now a close more closely
related to D than it is to the ancestor
of a and B even though in the species
history and this sequence of divergence
times the divergence of populations on C
was actually supposed to be more closely
related to a and that's in particular if
you're using this gene tree to try to
reconstruct the species history you're
going to get a mistake so this is
incomplete lineage so now what we're
trying to do here is to reconstruct this
bold trees your suppose that we're
interested in reconstructing the species
history which is this sequence of
speciation events we don't actually get
the seed directly what the species tree
is instead right we're going to look at
gene trees all right so for each gene
I'm going to reconstruct from from
sequence data a particular topology
then branch lines and I'm going to do
this for different genes and different
genes might give me different you might
give me different things now with this
collection of gene trees and the sort of
cloud of gene trees and my goal is to
try to recover the population the
species history ok so the original
species now in order to do this in a
sort of principle statistical way now I
have to model what is the distribution
of these different gene trees to be able
to take that into account and as we said
before it does sort of the natural model
here that's use in this literature is
called a multi-species coalescent and
also a species I'm very simple that in
each population you're doing a
coalescent and you join them together in
this tree and so in every population you
have a certain linear number of lineages
that enter it and then I to add a
certain rate every pair coalesce
according to the coalescent process and
then I by the end of a certain number of
lineages that are still surviving
they're going to enter the next
population they might be joined by
lineages coming from a different
population and then you start the
process over you have a co lesson of all
of these lineages and you repeat this
incident so that gives you a
distribution for these for these genes
and so once you sort of specify the
distribution you can look at your gene
trees and try to infer which species
tree is sort of likely to generate in
this particular collection of Jean drèze
now it was notice you know immediately
when people started trying to
reconstruct these feces trees in this
context that you that there's an
interesting issue which is that not only
is it possible for certain genes to
conflict with the actual species history
and it's actually possible that a
majority of your genes actually tell you
something that's different from what the
species history is for this local
anomaly zone suppose that you're
reconstructing a tree where all of the
branches at the bottom are very very
short what is going to happen well what
is the effect of these short branches
short branches here means that the
probability that the lineages that enter
here coalesce inside here is very
and what's going to happen is if I
follow one gene from each one of these
species it's very likely that knob them
is going to call s at the bottom instead
they are all going to enter this top
population together now once you enter
the top population together what happens
up there is just a standard coalescent
process and the cool essent process
really doesn't care about what happened
at the bottom of the species dream right
it just spits out a coup lesson tree and
it turns out that the the coalescent the
stang across and will is more like it
outputs they're balanced tree than a
been a more unbalanced the truth just
what I'm trying to represent here and so
in particular if you started with
species tree that was unbalanced well
you're out of luck the coalescent is
going to tend to spit out the more
balanced trees and you're going to get
in fact you can show that um in cases
like this you the most frequent topology
of your genes is actually going to be
different from the species topology make
sense okay so you have to be careful
when you're trying to reconstruct to
take that into account okay so we're
going to say that a method for
reconstructing a species trees
consistent is if as the number of genes
goes to infinity the the method you know
which starts from the gene trees and
outputs of species trees that method is
guaranteed to recover the correct tree
with high probability as the number of
genes ghosts and so what we just showed
in the previous slide is that this is
all the beggining and Rosenberg that was
mentioned before today is that if you if
your method is just to look at the most
common gene pre topology you're not
guarantee that this is going to be
consistent actually it could it could be
positively misleading kitsch it could
give you something that's guaranteed to
be the wrong thing as the number of
genes goes to me there's an important
exception here which I'm going to use
which is the tree taxon case if I have
only three species as a why mention then
it turns out that the most common
topology is the correct one is that the
one that corresponds to the species but
there's also lots of other methods for
getting around this problem of the fact
that the gene treat most common dream
feat apologies is
not the same as a species tree let me
describe briefly a couple of them
because I'm going to use them so for
this sort of more theoretical analysis
I'm going to restrict myself just for
simplicity to the three tax on case okay
so i have three species think of it as
human chimp and gorillas and i'm trying
to figure out which two of them are the
most closely related x is it human and
chimp or human grill and so on and i'm
going to assume that i have a molecular
clock these population sizes are all the
same this is a very a sort of a nice
case and basically what's going to
happen is that the shorter this branch
up here is look at the smaller f is f is
going to be the length of this branch
you can take of it as the probability
that two lineages call this year the
smaller f is the more incomplete
lineages learning is going to be the
harder is going to be to detect which
pair is closest yeah so here's one way
to to do this reconstruction if i give
you a bunch of topologies you can just
look at which one is the most frequent
one okay so in general that doesn't work
but if you have only three species that
actually works out and we're actually
show the formula for it okay so this is
a consistent method there are other
methods that instead of looking at
apology will actually take into account
branch lengths in particular this sort
of estimated coalescent time and just a
sort of a intuition about this works
what i'm showing you here is that ok so
for these are maybe this is not the best
picture these are not different
individuals these are just different
genes okay so what I'm trying to say
that there's a distribution of
coalescent times that depends on this
model and now the you sort of extract
information that allows you to
distinguish between a B being closest
versus ABC being closes well there's a
natural thing to do here which is just 2
for this pair for each pair you just
take the minimum of the coalescent times
that you're going to get right so for
each gene you get a different coalescent
time you get this distribution the
minimum is going to tend to converge
towards the actual divergence time under
the coalescent and therefore over here
it's going to be smaller than it
over there because they're the
coalescent the two closest one was
actually bc instead of a B is one way to
the reconstructed tree is just 2 for
every pair of species you look at the
smallest coalescent times that you see
across all your jeans and you compare
that then the two small the smallest one
will give you which pair is closest now
this is guaranteed to be I'm consistent
when the number of genes goes to
infinity another one thing is you can do
is just to average the coalescent times
that you see across the jeans i suffer
for these two species I have a bunch of
Kalessin times i can just average all of
them now this is not going to give me a
good estimate of the divergence time but
it will give me an estimate of something
that is going to be smaller here than it
is over there and if I just again look
at compare the average coalescing times
then the smallest one will correspond to
this the closest pair okay so that's
another way another consistent way of
getting the de triana okay so these are
in essence the sort of three classes of
methods for the three tax on case they
reduce other methods that are sort of
different for more taxa reduced to those
on so that the first one is the one we
are called our star at the probably the
most frequent apology the second one I'm
going to call glass which is the minimum
coalescent time across jeans and the
third one is going to be steak which is
the average coalescent timer question
and it turns out that i will use mls for
maximum likelihood if you're given the
coalescent times for all your jeans then
the maximum likelihood estimate of under
the multi species go lesson turns out to
be the same thing as taking the minimum
so you can prove that in this particular
context but i'm going to call this glass
okay so these are all consistent methods
if you really want to be able to sort of
compare them but it should remind me
what you want to do is to look at their
sort of convergence rate as a number of
genes goes to infinity you so the
guaranteed to converge to the true
topology but how many genes do you need
to get a high probability reconstruction
or you can compare you can compare that
between between these different methods
so this is the notation i'm going to use
in the next slide
for the convergence rate as if I think
at of the probability that a particular
method fails to detect that a and B were
the closest ones in this case it's going
to decrease exponentially so this is the
probably failure is going to decrease
exponentially as a number of genes goes
to infinity you can show that and it's
going to decrease at a certain rate R
which is going to depend on the method
and it's going to depend also on the
strength of the incomplete lineage
Sony's I'll short dis branches and by
comparing these ours you know you can
get you can figure out which methods are
sort of better than others so the bigger
they are the better so this is what you
get if you compute explicitly these are
these convergence rates for different
things so this is a result from last
year I'm not going to go in details over
this but what you can see that you have
sort of two different behaviors there's
this um remember this is our their rate
the exponential decay rate of failure
versus the length of this branch or the
shoulder it is the heart of the problem
is and the higher this value is the
better the method is so you see two
things here this ml or glass smitha the
one that takes the minimum as this sort
of linear dependence on the rate on s
whereas the other two the one that takes
the most frequent topology in the one
that takes the average across coalescent
times as a more quadratic dependence on
F because another way to think about
this is how many genes do I need to get
a ninety-five percent reconstruction
probability well this glass that are the
one it takes the minimum is going to
require of the order of 1 over F this is
the small thing 1 over F genes in order
to be able to do this correctly whereas
these guys are going to need 1 over F
square which is much bigger now why is
it 1 over F over here because remember f
is the probability that you have
coalescence in that small branch and if
you're taking the minimum as soon as one
gene coalescence inside that small
branch you're going to be able to detect
that the minimum here was there
than the minimum of another pair and so
in order since the probably is if it
picks up the order of 1 over F to
actually see one of them and that's why
you get this convergence rate whereas
the other one is sort of an average need
to kill some variants that somehow
depends on the square of this
probability okay so you can you can look
in more details that what happens in
different regimes and compare these
difference methods more specifically but
what I really want to focus on is what I
wrote here is it's sort of the noiseless
decay rate of failure why do i say noil
is because it doesn't take into account
the fact that in reality i don't
actually get the exact coalescent times
for each one of these genes I really get
some sequence data from which I estimate
those and there's going to be some error
there's going to be some noise in my
reconstruction of the coalescing times
in the end of topologies that are going
to affect potentially considerably this
picture and the question is what what
really happens there yes I want to I
want to go back and and and and do a
more refined analysis that actually
takes into account errors in estimating
different things for different genes
okay so what I have now is I have three
species ABC for each one of them I have
a genome this is a sequence which is
made of a bunch of different genes each
boxy or is a different gene there's G of
them okay so there's going to be two
parameters now the number of genes that
I have and I'd like to assume just for
this those simple analysis that every
gene has exactly the same length so
that's that's not true but it's a good
place to start l here is how long my
sequence is and of course when I guess
is that the shorter a particular gene is
another less signal i'm getting from
that gene the diffuse few mutations i
can see in a sense and the more
uncertainty there will be in what I can
reconstruct from that particular gene
okay so what's going to happen is now
for each one of these genes from this
sequence data I'm going to reconstruct
say a tree and some coalescing times
branch lengths estimates and from those
trees I'm going to get this this species
right now but what I just show you in
the previous slide is sort of an
an analysis of the step from here to
there if you were given the true gene
trees how well would you do in terms of
recovering the species tree and how much
data you need and so on but i really
want to also understand what happens in
this step and now the two of them
interact with each other and in fact and
if i can clear that i want to do this
side it could be that i just want to go
directly from the sequence data to the
species tree and there's a question of
well actually is it is it better to do
this or not can you prove anything can
you prove anything yes I now I want to
go back and analyze these metas again
are ready to devise some new methods
that will take into account ok this is
this entire thing I saw am I going to
model this I'm going to model this in a
sort of two stage process is the obvious
thing to do i first have my species tree
that according to multi-species
coalescent generates a bunch of gene
trees it's a very each gene this guy is
distributed reporting to the multi
species corazones there's some actual
branch line gear that i'm not showing
and then on each one of these gene trees
i'm going to just generate sequence data
using say the juke scanner model okay so
if you don't know juice can remodel I'm
it's just a model where you have a
certain sequence at the root of this
gene tree and along each branch at a
certain rate point mutations or sort of
accumulating at random and it generates
a sequence data for your leaves which
are the where the data is and so now
from this sequence idea I want to
recover the species dream and I want to
understand the same kind of questions
that is well is it consistent now in
that sense this is not no it's not the
same question anymore i'm looking at
different data and looking at
convergence or how much data do i need
in order to get a good reconstruction of
my species tree given my sequence data
and now it's a more complicated problem
is now it's two dimensional right how
much data do i need is is really well
there's the number of genes and there's
the length of each gene and you might be
interested in understanding really sort
of the trade-off between them and the
longer your genes are maybe you need
fewer of them and vice versa in general
is it better to have tons
short jeans or a few a smaller number of
longer jeans what sort of the trade-off
between within this what are methods
that work well in sort of different
parts of this picture so this is the
this is the goal and I I borrowing a
sort of candies terminology I I think of
this as a sort of quantity versus
quality question and if you think of L
as the quality of your signal light for
each gene the shorter it is the less
signal you're getting to know the lower
the quality of your data in a sense is
and you might and you can think of this
picture I sort of quality versus
quantity of your of your day if that
makes sense so far so let me tell you
what we and we figured out about this so
let me start with the sort of oldest
method for dealing with incomplete
lineage sorting which is to just ignore
to just ignore it so the first met that
is to apply maximum likelihood to this
concatenated data what do I mean by this
right we've already discussed this but
just remind you I have a bunch of jeans
so this is the genome of one species
what I can do is just pretend like
there's no differences between them and
I just concatenate them into one big
super gene and I do this for all of my
species so I gets a 3 supergene 11 for
each you mentioned gorillas and then I
run a maximum likelihood analysis on
these super jeans now what do I mean by
maksim likely i really mean the sort of
Miss specified maximum likelihood where
I just assumed that the super gene was
generated by a single gene tree I
completely ignored the multi species
school as an issue I have just one gene
tree generating these super jeans and I
want to find that the best fit the tree
that's an abyss with the data according
to this criteria so the maximum wanted
or you
domination I'm I'm assuming so in the
that's a good pressure right so in the
previous in there in the actual model
the way that the data is shared I'm
assuming that these are completely
independent so these are completely
unlinked I completely ignore the
recombination inside of it and I just
assume that they completely recombine
between them okay so under that
distribution what can you say about this
particular method okay so since it's
sort of Miss specified maximum likely
this is the natural to conjecture that
it's not going to work at least in some
cases there's been some empirical work
showing that indeed it can be
inconsistent although tansy showed that
sort of the jury is still out on in
practice whether or not you want to do
something like this or do maybe some
partial concatenation and so on on what
we can show there's a recent result with
my field is just to confirm the sort of
the via the intuition which is that not
only is this approach in general not
consistent it can be positively
misleading in other words for any
sequence length you can find a species
treat such that if you apply maximum
likelier to this concatenated data where
the data was generated onto the under
the multi species coalescent and the
juice can remodel but I'm ignoring that
when I'm reconstructing the tree with
maximal like you okay under that method
then you can find a species research
that this matter will converge to the
wrong tree with probability one as a G
goes to infinity geez a number of genes
so I fix a sequence length as the number
of gene goes to infinity I can show that
this is going to be an inconsistent and
and the reason that it is is um I can go
back to the sort of this anomaly zone
where you can have a particular gene
tree that's more likely than the actual
species tree in this case we're actually
going to need to look at six species
because this is the first time that you
get two different unrooted topology that
this is out for them but it's the same
idea if you make all of these benches
very short with high probability you can
make it such that these lineages all
sort of meet for the first time in that
top population that top operation just
lessened and the coalescent will tend to
favor certain topologies over others and
it really doesn't care about what you
started with all right and so in this
case um then maybe the balance tree is
going to be more likely than this one
now yes this mr connect this to what
maximum likelihood is doing which is not
picking the most likely thing or
anything it just it just puts all this
data together pretends like it's coming
from a one tree and tries to reconstruct
a tree what's going to happen there out
can you analyze this and there's sort of
a natural way to do this here is just
assume i am trying to find a
counterexample so i can assume anything
i'm going to take the mutation rate to
be as low very low and what happens when
the mutation rate is very low is that
maximum likelihood basically behaves
like something called parsimony what is
parsimony is it chooses a tree that
minimizes the number of mutations that
you have to put along the tree in order
to explain the data okay so it's a sort
of simpler more combinatorial quality
and once you've reduced this too
personally you can actually explicitly
compute the expected person only score
of the coalescent under the question of
different topologies and you can show
that the balance and one will have a
lower parsimony score than then the
unbalanced one and therefore maximum
likelihood will converge to the wrong
thing indeed okay so this particular
approach may work well sometimes in
practice but in theory it doesn't work
because it's not super surprising me now
as Tiny pointed out yes
it's a really simple simple proof right
this is it complicated or is it this
simple they made it look really hard
it's just a few pages okay now as Tandy
said inner talk not all concatenation is
evil and let me give you a different
take on this there's a natural variant
of the steak method that you can think
of as a concatenated method a steak
method remember is you take an average
of your coalescent times now I don't
have the coalescent times what I have is
a bunch of jeans how do i estimate the
coalescent time of a particular gene
well I'm going to measure the distance
between them i'm going to say compute
the hamming distance between the two
sequences and and thats related by
transformation to an estimate of the
coalescent i'm ok now in this particular
setting let's assume that I'm not doing
this transformation I can just work
directly with the Hamming distance for
each gene i compute the Hamming distance
between a and B and I I take the average
of all of those things across all the
genes and that gives me an estimate of
something which I can show is lower for
the closest pair now in my particular
setting where assume that all of the
genes are the same life and so on you
can actually think of this as the
Hamming distance of the super gene
instead of doing this one gene at a time
I can just count for each pair of super
gene how many differences there are here
i imagining sort of normalizing this by
the length of the sequence and that
gives me an estimate of something that
is shorter for the shortest player and
so you can think of this I'm going to
call the stake prime steak prime is
really concatenated method where it just
takes the hamming distance of every pair
of super jeans and just take the
shortest one to be the closest pair and
that turns out to
be a consistent method I can think of
this as a concatenation method it's
consistent and in fact you can prac Tice
I have to remember what I really want to
do is to understand not only whether
it's something is consistent or not but
whether what's of the trade-off between
how many genes I need and how much
signal i'm getting from each one of
these genes right and so on you can
correct rise this pretty well just to
get some attrition first let me just
show you a numerical computation of a
success probability of steak prime okay
so this is what am i showing you here
this is a plot of for various values of
G remember G is the number of genes L is
the length of each one of them right so
for each pair of LNG I'm showing you the
success probability of steak primer of
identifying the closest pair okay so red
means one blue means a half or one-third
depending alguma parametrize this way
let's just say I probability Loper milk
and so what you can see is that this
sort of this threshold where for any
particular length of your genes as you
get more and more jeans well the
probability of succeeding increases and
eventually this is sort of sharp
trade-off where where um end up quickly
having a probability of one of success
and in fact we already know what the
answer is as L goes to infinity because
this is the noiseless case when L goes
from Finland you get the actual Boston
by and there we showed that steak which
is very closely related to steak Prime
needs 1 over F square where is 1 over F
square here I took f2b 2.5% because
it'll probably have a coalescence inside
that small branch is two-point-five
percent and if you plot this on this
thing you get this F to the minus 2
which is a perfect very good fit where
where this step is happening like and
what you can see now is that as the
sequence line changes this particular in
Maya that is not very sensitive to how
much along your jeans all right so it
gets a little bit worse when the jeans
are shorter but not by a whole lot and
so you can prove this rigorously you can
prove that for any sequence light as
long as you have a the order of F to the
minus two genes you're going to succeed
steak prime is going to
hyper ability to identify the shortest
the shorter spear and the reason this is
this is the case is just because if i
write the variance with a sort of
conditional variance formula we are
conditioned on the actual true gene tree
there's a sort of a term coming from the
variance of the coalescent itself and
that thing really doesn't care about how
many hour longer sequences are and and
in the end and no matter what your
sequence length is you're always going
to sort of get the same answer which
basically depends on how many genes you
have okay so this is what you get for
stick and probably get the same thing
for steak I just didn't prove this
rivers little business joint work with a
good time that's all righty and Rob
Novak at the University of Wisconsin
okay so this is one method now what
about other methods there was this other
method which was glass all right this is
the one where instead of taking an
average you take a minimum of the
coalescent times I can do the same thing
as I just did instead of looking at the
coalescent times I have to estimate them
I'm going to take the Hamming distance
between every pair of jeans it's a fruit
now I'm not doing concatenation anymore
at all I have these different genes for
each one of them i take the Hamming
distance for every pair and I think the
minimum of dat across the jeans and the
smallest value I declared to be the
closest pair how well does that do well
that doesn't do very well and there's
been a lot of empirical work showing
that this is a terrible idea and it's
not very surprising minimum and you're
taking a minimum is not really a very
robust thing to do it just behaved very
badly was there's noise and so for
example the Georgia and Eggman in
systematic biology 2014 showed that for
a fix l so for fixed sequence length as
you get more and more and more genes
you're guaranteed that this Hamming
distance again I normalize it x divided
by the number of sites they're
normalized Hamming distance is going to
converge to 0 no matter what right
because what happens is as you get more
and more and more genes you have a
higher and higher probability of seeing
one gene where there was just no
mutations there I'm eventually this
thing is just going to converge
so that's a terrible thing and so you
just gonna get 0 for every pair and so
you don't get something that's
consistent now it's still informative to
look at what is the probability of
success for a different L&G and you get
a different picture here so this is the
same thing with the same probability of
coalescence red means hyperbole success
Blue means lover olya successes for this
glass method so taking the minimum of
the Hamming distances and what you can
see now is a very different behavior
where send out an order for this to
succeed you need to have a sequence link
that's long enough if your sequence is
too short no matter how many genes you
take your decisions you're not going to
work but as the sequence get longer and
longer eventually get to a point where
you can actually succeed at pleased with
some probability for a finite number of
genes and and if i plug the f how it
corresponds to the f well first of all I
know what the answer is in this limit
right so for glass we said it takes up
the order of 1 over F to see at least
one coalescence in that short branch in
order to be able to detect it with the
true coalescent times so this is the
limit over there and you consider it
goes there and in general what you need
is of the order of F to the minus 2
sequence length in order to succeed with
some fair reasonable probability and so
we can prove that this is a principle
this is how it compares to the stake
method which you can see it's a very
different picture or come back to the
difference between in a second but this
is what you can prove right then it's it
just follows some classical sequence
like requirement result of Plenty and
others that say that in order for every
gene to be sufficiently well
approximated that you can see when
something has been coalescing in that
short branch while you have the order of
F to the minus 2 genes which is what
this thing predicted okay let me move on
to what the real question is so these
are these two methods where you can say
something and I plotted the difference
between their success probability
rescale between minus 11 so your glass
succeeds well that steak doesn't and
there it's the opposite and what you can
see is that you know when you have a
large number of short jeans this stigma
that does very well when you have a
smaller number of long jeans this class
method goes works very well when both
are long or and there's a lot of them
both of them mark and then there's this
whole region here where we don't know
what's going on yes i'm going to call
this the mystery zone what happens over
here is it that there are no methods you
can do well there or is there a
different method that actually I'm
succeeded in that region okay so where
can we go looking for a better method at
their e61i notice that there's sort of a
natural way to dis interpolate between
these two method but yeah I'm trying to
interpolate between these two extremes
and that in my face and I grabbed
there's a natural way to interplay
between the two methods is to instead of
looking at the minimum or the average is
to look at some quantile all right and
you can pick up the average as being so
the median the half want i'll either
glad the minimum is is the sort of the
zero point out and general you know you
can look somewhere in between and it
makes sense to do this because if you
think about glass it's what a very same
inna mum is very sensitive to outliers
it makes sense to sort of days just
rejects a ten percent of the the lowest
data and then just take the next value
and compare those things in order to see
which one are closest how well does that
do well there's one issue there which is
which quantile should I choose ok so
that's the question and I'm gonna go
fast through this which quantel do you
want to choose I said what I'm plotting
here is that you know I have two
different distances I'm measuring the
Hamming distance for them and what I'm
showing you is that the distribution of
the normalized Hamming distance is right
so there's the green and the blue one
that are slightly different if there was
no noise at all I would just get this
step function but because of the
sequence noise I get this little smeared
distribution and the shorter my
sequences the sort of the this more
spread out this thing is going to be I
guess the answer oops wrong direction
what I want to do is to to figure out
well what quantiles should i use and
some of that should depend on i'll
spread out this distribution is enough
if i write this is the same thing i just
wrote to draw you the cumulative
distribution function and if i look at
the difference between the cumulative
the street
motion that's going to tell me some of
which quantile is going to work best
well it's somewhere over here which
correspond roughly to the divergence
time in terms of Hamming distance
expected Hamming distance you have to be
careful though once you once you look at
this you have to also think about the
the standard deviation of the oldest so
here I'm taking the standard deviation
of looking at a particular quanta
dividing divided by the difference of
the CDF and you can sort of see that at
this minimum I get sort of the best
possible value which correspond roughly
in terms of the CDF to a power of l to
the minus one-half it's like an ax minus
point for here on this particular
assimilation of my CD ok so this is the
the algorithm I'm going to compare the
one over square root K quantiles of my
distributions it's like I reject the
first one over square root K 1 over
square root L values and I look at this
particular and compare those a Gautam
calls this the quest method and what you
can show is that well first of all it's
consistent but let's look at let's look
at the actual distribution success
probability ok so this is what you get
in this case you get a very different
picture where now you have this sort of
linear interpolation between these these
two regimes with a slope of minus
one-half and if you compare this to
these two guys right you can see that it
sort of interpolates between the two
steak might do a little bit better here
glass might be it a little bit better
there but in between the sort of quest
method where you choose the white point
I'll is the one that
doesn't this so you can prove this
rigorously let me not explain how the
proof works this one is somewhat less
trivial but not very difficult what you
get is that the amount data that you
need the number of genes has to scale
like this F to the minus 2 but / squared
L so the more data you have the longer
know the longer the sequences are the
less the fewer genes you need let me
skip the proof and other then the last
question is can we do better than this
okay so what do we have we have these
three methods if i should superpose them
this is the best of the three for each
possible value of Jean Elle and can I
can I can I can I you know push this
even further in this regime where our
shorter sequences in the other genes and
it turns out that the answer is no you
can set this up as this you can get a
bound as a sort of set this up as i
bought this is testing problem where
you're testing between these two
hypotheses you're looking at the
distribution of these two things and you
lose a likelihood ratio test to
distinguish between the distribution of
this hamming this sensitization this
hamming distance and what I'm going to
show you here is a an upper bound of the
success probability of this particular
this particular likelihood ratio test
which is so the best thing that you
could hope to do here and you can see
that it sort of fits exactly or pretty
closely what the best of these three
methods so in the end this F to the
minus 2 over square root L is somehow
the the optimal trade-off between these
two things and you can prove this
rigorously by computing the hell in your
distance between these distributions if
this is this particular part this is
much more technically challenging but in
the end you can do this and you show
that this this thing is really the
optimal that you can possibly hope to do
in terms of the trade-off between the
number of genes and the sequence length
so just to summarize and what I said
this is the phase diagram if you have
fewer than 1 over F jeans
thing you can do and then above this
slope minus one-half which comes from
taking the log of this you get this
minus one-half over here and these
various methods working these different
regimes and that's really the best that
you can do and then if you're below that
you're just some just to conclude some
interesting consequences of this and
suppose that I go back to the question
of how much data do I need if you
measure the amount of data that you need
in terms of the Storrow sequencing
effort okay so the number of genes send
the length of the GG times L how does
that scale with the sequence length well
if you do the computation right in that
previous picture I can say for every L I
can find the optimal G if I if I if I
compute GL for this particular curve
again that it grows as a square root of
L in other words so remember that L
measures the quality of my data the
higher the quality is sent out over all
the more total amount of data I'm going
to eat or in other words you're much
better off having tons of short jeans
than a few were longer jeans as long as
what you care about is the sort of total
sequencing effort that you're doing in
order to get the best possible
reconstruction and other consequence of
this is that if you're just reducing
things to do in topologies from
different genes and combining them
together in general we can show that you
need 1 over F square whereas if you
start directly from the sequence data
and go to the species true then you get
to remove sub divided by square root
gamma which can be much better engine
okay so there's a lot more to do here
and one thing that I've done is to
assume that all the genes are the same
lack obviously that's not gonna be too
true differentiating they give you
different signals i love you sort of
combine this together and what can you
prove about this different genes might
have different rates also so this is
little related I've really done that the
whole analysis based on sort of
distances formally well the met the
method right based on this is this but
you might you know you might want to try
to prove something about the full the
distribution of the data look at more
than three species and so on I haven't
had time to talk about the work I've
been doing
handy which is to a sort of different
take on this as a model instead of
modeling a sequence data modeling the
estimation errors that you do in the
gene treason and seeing Alden effects of
various methods but that's for another
collaborators thank you how is the
mutation rate in service alright notice
there's a 1 over the square root oh yes
that's a one I say that I take this the
sequence lon somehow the mutation rate
Egyptian should that come in I haven't
exactly oh so I just so you can just
sort of scale it out I guess it's long
enough that you got for one mutation for
that link over the tie game vector
course yes
yes now since i'm a quick question are
going to say if you do entries with a
phylogenetic methods 0 lengths are going
to be in units of substitutions for
science and all that gene develop
different great yes you're picking
listen to the shortest branch lengths it
just means that that gene is it all more
slowly because position because I
stronger so like yes answer that was one
of the future allure question how do you
take into account the fact that
different genes are evolving have
potentially in different speed so you
you would have to do something different
or try to take into account package it's
not obvious to me how it fits into this
yeah I was actually going to ask that
question also and also so if the person
was starting to do this on actual
genomes then your your jeans don't
necessarily have to be jeans and a cable
i prefer to stay away from actual genes
because the render selection so then
there's there's the question of finding
syntenic regions so there's they're sort
of the trade up like you want region and
maybe
let's just say that you want lots of
short girls in the same characters right
like how the criteria that someone might
choose oh jeez health issues
okay so any more questions let's thanks
Sebastian than everyone